[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si tu veux de
Moi pour t'accompagner Au bout des
jours laisse-moi venir près de toi
Sur le Grand char de pois et de
toile nous nous fr
fers de couté d'o montera le
[Musique]
aujourd'hui dans les premières réflexions de
ciel avant la chaleur du
Soleil sous la dernière étoile
la Plaine la Plaine la plaine n'aura Plus
de fronti la terre la terre pour être à notre
domain que j'aime que j'aime ce vieux
chalou qui t quit quit quit si tu veux de
Moi pour dormir ton cé
toujours
l'été sous la lune d'argent
l'hiver le alors dis-le-moi
[Musique]
toire la pline la pline la pline n'aura
Plus de franti la terre la terre sera
notre t j'aime que j'aime ce vieux
charot Qui langue qui langue qui langue
si tu veux de
Moi de ma vie et de mon pauvre
je l'aime des temp et des
bois Au cur des dangers et des joies tout
dis à Moi Au sécurité je pars avec
toi
Yo